in our first story facebook
whistleblower frances haugen uh went
before the senate yesterday and did a
great job i think she was well spoken
and
i think moderate in her proposed
solutions for
the challenges of social media facebook
circled the wagons and came out swinging
and in fact many of the
facebook surrogates the people who are
one or two
uh
steps removed from facebook were out
there uh attacking her including their
pr team we should be clear about what
her goals are and i think that's
part of this we we are
obviously uh now entering the phase of
attack
the messenger and
let's figure out what the messenger's
motivation is right and i guess that's
valid right you do have to think about
who is making these claims why are they
making these claims why are they making
these claims now and maybe what are they
hoping to get out of this sometimes you
will see this and somebody is
got an axe to grind maybe they were
fired maybe they didn't get their stock
options
they didn't get a promotion
or sometimes it's virtuous and they um
are doing this because they
believe it's in the best interest of
society or maybe they have some id uh
ideological position but let's hear it
from uh francis herself a one minute
clip and i'll talk to you on the other
side during my time at facebook i came
to realize a devastating truth almost no
one outside of facebook knows what
happens inside of facebook the company
intentionally hides vital information
from the public from the us government
and from governments around the world
the documents i have provided to
congress prove that facebook has
repeatedly misled the public about what
its own research reveals about the
safety of children the efficacy of its
artificial intelligence systems and its
role in spreading divisive and extreme
messages as long as facebook is
operating in the shadows hiding its
research from public scrutiny it is
unaccountable until the incentives
change facebook will not change these
problems
are solvable a safer free speech
respecting more enjoyable social media
is possible but there is one thing that
i hope everyone takes away from these
disclosures it is that facebook can
change but is clearly not going to do so
on its own congress can change the rules
that facebook plays by and stop the many
harms it is now causing we now know the
truth about facebook's destructive
impact okay this is uh i think
critically important number one
she believes the problems are solvable
she's credible and believes the problems
are solvable
so she is not asking for facebook to be
broken up she is
actually saying
we can make
a social media landscape that is um
less
polarized and that is safer for
everybody and that maybe doesn't have
downstream effects on mental illness or
politics elections misinformation she's
an expert on the subject she's highly
credible and she believes it's solvable
i actually
think it's less solvable i think this is
just one of these problems that you know
we've never had as a society you know i
don't know billions of people on these
platforms even if it was tens of
millions of people there's never been a
town square
that's 10 million people and that one
tweet or one tick tock or one story on
instagram or snapchat could become the
number one
uh media object in the world same thing
with youtube this has never existed in
the history of humanity
she thinks it's solvable i actually
i think it's
less solvable i think than she does
and her solution for solving it let's
talk about that second piece so hey she
believes it's solvable b
her solution
is not breaking up facebook
it's forcing facebook to be more
transparent and to publish all their
research
uh so that is
very interesting to me um this is not
the aoc bernie sanders elizabeth warren
all rich people are bad all capitalism
is bad
giant conglomerates are bad break them
up regulate them tax them shut them down
that that's she's not clearly not part
of that camp you do not get the bernie
bro
elizabeth warren aoc squad vibe from her
do you
you don't get an anti-tech vibe from her
either
the vibe i'm getting
is
let's work together to solve this so
when she gets more specific she says
listen congress should have a regulatory
body where people like her can work on
making algorithms safer anybody disagree
with that anybody disagree that
something this powerful and
unprecedented should have some
regulation i mean i'm not for
over-regulation but we're in a situation
where there's no regulation and you've
got to remember with facebook facebook
is um
i wouldn't say left or right leaning
they're peter thiel leaning when it
comes down to it zuckerberg and teal
and that whole crew are very much in
favor of no regulation and they're kind
of ann randian in their objectivist you
can look up those fancy words it
basically means
people should be you know talented
people should be allowed to do what they
want and not be stopped by
people in their ivory towers like
politicians or the media or professors
right they are anti-cathedral
and they're you know more about the
marketplace and and the uh
yeah the bizarre
not bizarre isn't strange but the
bizarre is in the marketplace of ideas
but i think for the rest of us
yeah cigarettes yeah maybe we should uh
regulate those a little bit and the vape
pens yeah there should be some
regulation there those are those are
pretty bad for society yeah you know
social media it's having some weird
effects we should definitely think about
it because the russians are using it to
screw with the elections um
we should definitely have some
regulation there
her second idea is just publish all the
research i mean
is anybody against that i mean the only
people who i could think would be
against that is people who want to front
run the research like the internal
people on facebook i mean
i think the reason facebook is
doing the research is twofold one they
care
i do actually think that they care uh
about what the research says but two i
think they want to control the research
and they want to control the researchers
so
this is like you know keep your enemies
closer kind of situation for facebook if
they bring the researchers in house
and they're funding them and they work
for them well then they can keep this
from escaping and they can control it
and they can front run it which is
exactly what they did with this research
they are front running this research
they are massaging it
and that is why this person felt like
they needed to front run or they needed
to leak the front running of the
information does that make sense i think
we can all
kind of see what facebook is doing there
buy the researchers bring them in-house
and
yeah it's not great that you're paying
for research that is working against you
which was zuckerberg's reply and we'll
get into his response like why would we
pay for this you know like why would we
pay for research if we didn't care it's
a pretty it's a pretty good defense i'll
be totally honest and and it's half true
i think i think they do want to know and
they do want to pay for this research
because it is helpful for them and i do
think
you know they do have uh
you know i don't i wouldn't say they
have
the users and the citizens best interest
in mind i think they think first about
the size of their company and the growth
of it and exactly they do think about
the customers but
you know it's in that order
so this is a very interesting uh
strategy and a highly effective one
in today's startup landscape committing
to security and compliance is vital for
growth and proof of your company's
security posture has never been more
important as you scale you might start
to receive more sock two requests from
customers and that's where drata comes
in drata is an advanced automation
platform used by some of the world's
leading chief information security
officers or csos strata will help you
successfully meet requirements support
enterprise deal flow and continually
track compliance drata also helps
customers easily prepare for and clear
sock 2 and other audits so you can go
from zero to audit ready in a matter of
weeks need more take it from philip
martin chief security officer at
coinbase and here's his quote it became
clear to me right away that drata is an
engineering powerhouse the solution
they've developed is well ahead of other
market players their approach to deep
native integrations provides users with
the most advanced automation available
so check out drata's 5 star reviews on
g2 and see why companies like clearco
smart recruiter and the good face
project work withdrata for their
compliance needs twist listeners can get
15 off and waived implementation fees at
drata.com twist d-r-a-t-a dot com slash
twist